Now The Man Behind today's effort that
led to the ouster of the now former
speaker Kevin McCarthy Congressman Matt
Gates joins me live Congressman thanks
for being with us tonight I want to get
right to the criticism of Chief
criticism by some of your GOP colleagues
that we've been covering that in in the
angle made the point that it took your
aligning with Democrats and even Pals of
Liv's Cheney and the Republican party
like Ken Buck to produce a result that
as of now has no solution so what's your
response to that
the solution's quite easy we should get
to electing a new more conservative more
trustworthy speaker immediately and I'm
calling on Patrick Patrick McHenry Who
currently is the speaker Pro tem to
reconsider the decision that he just
made to send everyone in Congress home
for a week this is not the time to go
home for a week we should stay and elect
a new speaker that's the path ahead as
far as the criticism that I worked with
Democrats the yellow brick road of
working with Democrats was paved by
Kevin McCarthy whether it was the debt
limit deal whether it was the continuing
resolutions this is a guy who was
willing to partner with conservatives on
the frivolous but whenever there was a
spending matter he partnered with
Democrats that said speaker McCarthy's
time is over I wish him well I have no
personal animus to him I I hope he finds
fruitful pastures and I'm certain he
will but we've got a job to do here this
is about the job this is about keeping
our commitment to have single subject
spending bills and an actual budget for
the first time we've already established
tonight that that we I mean I have been
doing this with all due respect decades
longer than you okay you're a young guy
and so I agree with all I don't believe
that Laura yeah when you were like three
continuing resolutions the budget the
spending all it's a total nightmare
but the fact of the matter is y'all
don't have the votes you don't have the
margin to from get to get from A to B to
C and so how does this get you closer I
categorically reject it we don't how do
you get budget hold on a second Matt how
do you get closer to to all these things
that that are legitimate concerns when
you still have a senate that says no can
do I mean you got you got several
Senators who are actually completely on
the other side on a lot of those you
still have that the contentment so how
do you get to your Nirvana points which
are the conservative Holy Grail points
of governance
the Senate does not control how the
house approaches its spending business
so hold on Congressman hold on hold on
because we got to go to McCarthy now
he's speaking live but then you can
respond on the other side
if Reagan gave us advice he would say
if you believe your principles bring
people greater Freedom you should be
happy about it
I've always been I've always been
excited that I've been a happy
conservative
but I've always believed
that I've been so fortunate
to be an American
my journey to this office
was something people wouldn't understand
I grew up in a town of Bakersfield
California the son of a firefighter
the grandson of immigrants
parents worked hard youngest in my
family
didn't have great wealth and got out of
high school I didn't have great grades
couldn't get a scholarship went to
Community College
flipped cars to try to pay my way
through it went to visit some buddies
wave college for a weekend stopped at
the grocery store to cash a check and I
won the lottery
one of the first in California it was
before Biden economics there's only five
thousand but it went much further back
then
took my folks to dinner
put the majority of the rest of the
money into the stock market and did
pretty well
the next semester I took a break from
school
I went to buy a franchise but no one
said they would sell me one
is only 20 years old
but I learned then never to give up so I
opened my own business
selling sandwiches
three things I learned first to work
last to leave last to be paid
I wanted to finish my college degree at
that time no one in my family should
finish the four-year degree I did pretty
well and now had enough money that I
could pay my way through school as long
as I went to Cal State
I sold my business going to school I
opened up the local paper and said be a
summer intern in Washington DC with my
local congressman
I did not know this man but I thought
he'd be lucky to have me so I applied
you know what he did he turned me down
but you want to know the end of the
story I got elected to the seat I
couldn't get an internship for I ended
up being the 55th Speaker of the House
one of the greatest honors I loved every
minute the one thing I will tell you is
doing the right thing isn't always easy
but it is necessary
I don't regret standing up for choosing
government
over grievance
it is my responsibility it is my job
I do not regret negotiating
our government is designed to find
compromise
I don't regret my efforts to build
coalitions and find Solutions
I was raised to solve problems not
create them
so I may have lost a vote today but as I
walk out of this chamber I feel
fortunate to have served the American
people
I leave the speakership with a sense of
Pride accomplishment and yes optimism
from the day I entered politics my
mission has always been to make tomorrow
better than today
I fought for what I believe in and I
believe in this country of America
my goals have not changed
my ability to fight is just in a
different form
you need 218. unfortunately four percent
of our conference can join all the
Democrats
and dictate who could be the Republican
speaker in this house
I don't think that rule is good
for the institution
but apparently I'm the only one
I believe I can continue to fight maybe
in a different manner
I will not run for speaker again
I'll have the conference pick somebody
else
I hope you realize that every day I did
the job regardless whether you
underestimated me or not I wanted to do
it with a smile
I grew to enjoy you even on your
toughest days and your questions
I could always tell what day it was
based upon your question
Monday you would ask if I could pass the
bill
Tuesday was whether the rule would pass
Wednesday was the greatest challenge
ever to my speakership
and Thursday when we passed the bill you
didn't think it was a very big deal
and it all started again on Friday
you know
I wouldn't change a thing
um
I do believe
I got a new portrait in there too of
Teddy Roosevelt
you all know the man in the arena
one of my favorite parts of it who airs
who comes up short again and again but
there is no effort without error and
shortcoming
worthy cause who knows the Triumph of
high achievement and if he fails at
least he fails while daring greatly
I always like to take a risk
Saturday I took a risk for the American
public
regardless what anybody says
no one knew whether that would pass
the Democrats didn't want that bill
yes they pull a fire alarm yes they do
their conga line yes they wanted to
delay
but it was all for the American people I
could not look the troops in the eye
and say I would not pay them
for those who spoke on the floor
I thank them for their positive talks
I don't know what those who voted
against and said there some deal they
were never a part of any deal
for those who said
about what we accomplished I'm proud of
what we accomplished from the parents
Bill of Rights
to our Energy bill
but if they want to hold me liable
because the Senate didn't take it up or
the president didn't take it up
that's politics for what I know but the
one thing I do know
this country is too great for small
visions of those eight
to any child that are listening and who
are coming to visit the capitol this is
a place I want you to visit
I liked opening the capital back up
again I like taking away the metal
detectors I liked committees to being
able to work I like people being able to
visit I hope you like being able to be
back in I think it was important that
that members actually show up to work as
well
you know to paraphrase Lou Gehrig
he said
I might have been given a bad break
but I truly still consider myself to be
the luckiest man on the face of the
Earth
there's no other country
that you could rise to be the 55th
speaker not get an internship
and be able to fight for the American
public so it was my greatest honor to be
able to do it I love my conference well
I love to be able to Ability I've been a
part of the leadership team for quite
some time we won two majorities
as leader I'm proud of the fact we only
gain races
only gain seats I'm proud of the fact is
a Republican leader we elected more
women we elected more minorities we
expanded the base I'm proud of the fact
that for the five years I lead her two
election Cycles we gained five more
seats in California five more in New
York we won in places no one thought we
could win the same thing you would
underestimate me you always said we'd
lose each time around we kept gaining I
intend to make sure that we gain and
keep the majority in the next cycle as
well with that I look forward to your
positive questions
oh I'll look at that
person we've heard you say approximately
ten thousand times that you never give
up so I'm wondering why not why'd you
make a decision not to put your name
before together and try to grind it out
like you did when you won the job in the
first place
you know you need 218 for the rule 218
um
to move forward and I'll never give up
on the American people that doesn't mean
I have to be speaker
to do what I have to do for the American
people
um
there's a lot of things I could do for
the American people
but you know what's interesting
everybody's sitting there
in today's world if you're sitting in
Congress
and you took a gamble to make sure your
government was still open
and eight people can throw you out a
speaker
and the Democrats who said they wanted
to keep government open
I think you've got a real divide
I think you've got a real institutional
problem
interesting it was in this room
after we had won the majority I had
became speakerless and Nancy Pelosi came
to me she was speaker at the time on the
way out
I told her I was having issues with
getting enough votes she said what's the
problem I said they want this one one
person and can really out she was the
only speaker that changed that rule I
had the power to call the vote on her
but I never would I lost some votes
because of it
um and she said just give it to him
I'll always back you up I made the same
offer to Boehner and same thing
to Paul because I believe in the
institution
I think today was a political decision
by the Democrats and I think I think the
things they have done in the past hurt
the institution
they just started removing people from
committee they just started doing the
other things and I my fear is the
institution fell today
because you can't do the job
if eight people you have 94 of or 96
percent of your entire conference but
eight people can partner with the whole
other side
how do you govern and for them to make a
motion on me because I made a decision
for the country
that they agreed with
but they choose to do the other that
becomes a problem
I might I might yeah I don't know I
don't know who's running I'll talk to
people
when you look back is there anything
that have done differently to what those
eight members yeah a lot a lot of them I
helped get elected so I probably should
have picked somebody else
[Music]
don't give up on
YouTube Banks here there's others that
really really support you you know
again you know I love these 200 they've
gone through so much they're down in the
conference they they will they want me
to they'll say they're going to keep
vote for me
um
I I think you should put the country
first
you know this job was never about me
I hope you felt that this
that
I always felt what can we do with best
to move forward I mean
I
I treated Hakeem the way I wanted to be
treated I'd tell them things we're doing
throughout so he never knew so he never
was questioned I wanted to bring the
body back differently
we created a select committee on China I
changed the Intel committee they just
came back from MIT where they all had
bipartisan briefing on AI and Quantum
started doing briefings with AI the
whole Conference of Republicans and
Democrats alike
we're far from solving that problem but
I'm proud of what we were able to do
there so we'll continue yes sir
you know
um
not all those eight but these are the
same people
that never voted for me they thought it
was big they went to present
after we went through 15 rounds
um
why do I do something for myself that
can hurt the country what why create I'm
not quite sure those individuals are
looking to be productive
it concerns me as a Republican based
upon watching what they do I want to be
a Republican and a conservative
that governs
and we're going to have to find our way
to do that the challenge is we had so
many opportunities these are the same
people that sat on the floor and
criticized me that we didn't get all 12
spending Mills done but we first had to
do a debt ceiling
that they didn't support
they held up every appropriation bill in
the summer because they wouldn't let it
come through after the debt ceiling they
stopped us from doing anything on the
floor when we had a continuing
resolution that would do something on
the border I listened to one talk about
how it made them think about the border
and when he voted against it
and then they wanted to challenge me
because I worked with the other side so
America could go forward and government
could stay open you know if you have to
lose for something
I will always lose for the country
it it is a much better battle to have
change the rules
[Music]
do you think I let it
I mean for the whole point I mean if you
talk about like a gates the gates came
to the whole conference said we will
never use this we'll never use this you
know I mean this is a man that sat there
on the 14th vote and said okay I'm going
to vote for you next time it falls back
and not so I mean it's just the
trustworthiness of a lot of individuals
it makes it difficult but I do not think
regardless of who the speaker is that
you should have that rule it you know
everybody had it but Pelosi but it was
never used until it started getting used
against uh Boehner and
if if the entire other if you can always
count on the other party to vote and the
block against it then you're allowing
four to five people
to control whatever so it doesn't matter
even if you have 96 percent
so that is not a government that works
that is chaotic
okay go right ahead
[Music]
about a challenge
I wonder what do you think this means
what it says
I don't think it says about the
Republican party I think it says
something about some people who are not
a conservative
I mean if you were conservative and you
only had one entity making the battle
and you vote against securing the Border
you vote against cutting fund this
wasteful spending and then you partner
with all the Democrats now you'll phrase
it all the other different ways that's
not a conservative look you all know
Matt Gates
you know it was personal
it had nothing to do about spending
it had nothing to do about everything he
accused somebody of he was doing
it all was about getting attention from
you
I mean we're getting email fundraisers
from him as he's doing it
join in quickly
that's not governing that's not becoming
of a member of Congress
and regardless of what you think I've
seen the text it was all about his
ethics but that's all right
foreign
he asked about that I haven't thought
about that I said yeah
no no I'm not going to blame anybody
there's not blame anywhere look
I give it as good as I get it right so
it's you you know the challenge I knew
going in you would take a poll all the
time is he going to get thrown out this
week but you know what
if I lose my job
over doing what I truly believe what's
right I'm very at peace with it you
asked earlier like when did I decide
I knew they would make the motion on me
it didn't make one bit of difference I
felt very comfortable in that decision
and I think the American public believed
that decision was right
that's the conferences decision
um you mentioned that you were looking
to maybe help this bill in another way
when you consider it having a good
of his leadership
no no no no no no no I I there's a lot
of great people in conference there's
always other people to do jobs it is
amazing the talent that we have and the
one thing I've always hoped as Speaker
that we lifted more of that Talent up I
look at people doing a lot of different
jobs in the different opportunities we
did and they're doing an exceptional job
we we have so much talent it is it is
remarkable yes
that's
that kind of old stuff
well would any of you think if it took
that long and you had a one person you
knew it was always a possibility so that
was fine
um
didn't bother me didn't change any of my
decision I made but it was interesting I
read a tweet the other day of Matt
Rosendale
um
he goes to massive every day but you
know what he said his prayer was all
last year
that Republicans didn't have a big
victory that they had a narrow victory
when you have members like that
that are part of your team you got a
tough team yeah look when I was in
business I got to hire and fire who
worked with me
somebody else hires him somebody else
fires him my job was to inspire them
I think we did some good work and I
think we'll continue to do great work
yes sir
you Paul Ryan Eric Cantor yeah
we're not that young anymore
no let's be fair and it's wrong that you
ever say
they are not conservatives
they voted against one the greatest cut
in history that Congress has ever voted
for two trillion they voted against work
requirements they voted against NEPA
reform they voted against border
security they voted against God they
don't get to say they're conservative
because they're angry and they're
chaotic
that's not the party I belong to the
party of Reagan was if you believed in
your principles that you could govern in
a conservative way they are not
conservatives and they do not have the
right to have the title
yes
why do you say that
because your question doesn't hold true
to history
When Donald Trump was President we did
tax reform
you can look at all of our different
successes so I mean you may dislike the
policy but we've been very successful
you you watched the Abraham Accords I
mean you can go Victory after Victory
the price of gas we were energy
independent at the time we had more
businesses growing at the time we didn't
have to evacuate our embassies
you know
it's easy on its Merit to see the
difference of what Biden has destroyed
America to what the policies we were
able to create
yes sir
no we didn't ask for anything
[Music]
no no no
um and you know I have a lot of respect
for hucking
all right we'll continue to monitor that
but back with me now is Congressman Matt
Gates Congressman I know you've been
listening in to former speaker
McCarthy's comments uh he name checked
you and said number one you're not a
real conservative because you don't want
to govern conservatively he also said
that this really was personal intimating
that you're really PO'd that he didn't
step in and put down that ethics
investigation into you and he knows it's
personal and you know it's personal and
you say
that's totally false I'm the most
investigated man in the entire United
States Congress I've been cleared by the
FBI doj the Federal Election Commission
but you don't think that McCarthy did
enough to stop this I mean isn't that no
it wasn't that Wellness
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with being mad by the way I'm not by the
way the beginning of speaker McCarthy's
comments there were lovely and nice
about his past and his history but when
he says we're not conservative because
we didn't vote to secure the Border I
think that does Merit a response we
passed a Department of Homeland Security
border bill that would have required
e-verify with a host of other reforms
then on a continuing resolution Kevin
McCarthy wanted us to surrender every
other fight
Jack Smith weaponized government
everything else going on just to isolate
the Border thing now I don't believe
that the way conservatives get ahead is
surrendering everything but the Border
in order to address the border and I
don't think that the way to address the
border is to passive verify and then say
that the strong border position is the
abandonment of you verify in a vote that
occurs 14 years
you're not going to get that border
you're not going to get what you want on
the border none of us are until you get
the numbers in the house and you kick
out some of these things frankly Laura I
think it's worse than that I think we're
going to secure the Border until we have
the white house but I also want to
address this notion that we aren't
conservatives right because what Kevin
McCarthy believes about governing is
that we have to utilize these continuing
resolutions and if the continuing
resolution is conservative enough if you
hang some bells and whistles on it that
that really ought to pacify people who
are right-leaning throughout the country
I believe that the only way to achieve
programmatic reform and to put downward
pressure on spending is to do what was
done back in the 90s where every
individual bill is conferenced and
debated and subject to Amendment and of
course you have to compromise and of
course you have to govern matter of fact
just last week I voted for four
Appropriations bills after my amendments
were largely defeated by yeah
but they're making a point tonight
Congressman we only have limited time so
if you don't mind me Moving on but I we
made that point about what you did last
week but look I think the concern here
is that there people are seeing your
fundraisers instantly going out about
this you're raising money and it's it it
is chaos
it's not a fundraiser I think we have a
full screen of it is it is it a
fundraiser or not and everybody
fundraises again I'm not I'm not just by
the way that is another criticism of
what's going on if I can get a word in
here yeah if I can get a word in here I
am the only Republican in the entire
United States Congress who takes no
lobbyist money and no Pac money so
absolutely absolutely I communicate
daily vigorously with regular Americans
because the only way I'm able to to
advance my political goals is if just
regular folks give me 10 20 30 and so I
will take no lecture from the likes of
people who do three lobbyist fundraisers
a day and trade favors in order to get
cash from special interest on how I
raise money and I take deep offense to
anyone who wants to criticize
the the mailman the active duty service
member the grandmother who believes in
me and goes to mattgates.com to donate
matter of fact I hope they do that right
now and I'm not sorry for it at all
because I won't take the lobbyist and
pack money like every other person here
does well I think that's awesome that
you don't I think it's fantastic by the
way um do you plan to stay in the house
are you planning have you thought of
running for office like maybe the
governor's race in 2026 what is your
thought there you know what Laura I
think I'm exactly where I need to be
doing exactly what I need to be doing
what I'm not thinking about it doing is
ensuring that we have what's that you're
not thinking about it at all I mean come
on you're up
I'm doing there's nothing wrong
Harry Potter I'm not running for
governor in 2026 I am here serving in
the house in 2023 trying to get a budget
why is it when I'm trying to get a
budget in single subject bills and
return to pre-coveted spending all
everyone's interested is in a political
race that's three years from now I am
here doing this job my voters elected me
to do this and that is what I have
endeavored to do at times with a very
small group of people but dedicated
people because we have to send a shock
wave through Washington DC you have to
change this down we have to change the
system Congressman president Trump uh
took to truth social this afternoon and
he said that why is it the Republicans
are always fighting among themselves why
aren't they fighting the radical left
Democrats who are destroying our country
now I know you've had conversations with
President Trump and you intimated that
he was you know you understood where he
was coming from and it seemed to
indicate that maybe he was
maybe in favor of what you were doing
but wasn't going to say so publicly what
can you tell us tonight since he really
is the leader of the party and you are a
Maga Republican and he's the top dog so
what do you say
absolutely I support president Trump
eager to campaign with him probably our
private conversations I'm going to keep
to us but I think I'm in pretty good
stead with the former president you'll
see me on the campaign trail with him
soon and by the way you know who you
won't see on the campaign Trail at a big
rally Kevin McCarthy because if Kevin
McCarthy took the stage at a trump rally
he would be booed off of it like Lindsey
Graham
well Congressman do you think that let's
say next year and who knows how this is
all going to play out but next year
November or whatever it is 8th fifth
sixth
Republicans lose the House of
Representatives because Democrats think
this is going to help them they wanted
McCarthy out the Democrats wanted
McCarthy out just as much looks like as
you did so let's say Republicans lose
the house will you feel any
any regret for having done what you did
today
absolutely not I believe that we were
destined to lose the house if we didn't
do what we did today because we didn't
give anyone Something to Believe In I've
traveled all over this country and I
have seen the despondence and the
sadness and conservatives who don't
believe that republicans in Congress are
fighting enough for them half of your
monologues every night are about the
failures of house conservatives to
really dig in and fight you are in many
ways a true north to try to help us
focus on the things that that matter in
in these contentious debates and
discussions over legislation but you
know what we're not going to lose the
house and you know why because Donald
Trump is going to drag a bunch of people
to Victory who probably wouldn't have
deserved it otherwise but that's what
happened in 2016 2020 was a was another
good year for Republicans at the
Congressional level so when Trump's on
the ballot we do pretty well and I
suspect that we'll do well when he's our
nominee Congressman we really appreciate
you responding to McCarthy and joining
us tonight thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else